PROFESSOR: Now we can use the
unique path characterization
of trees to very
quickly figure out
that every tree is 2-colorable.
So we know that a tree is
a graph with unique paths
between every pair of vertices.
And as a consequence,
the chromatic number
of a tree with two or
more vertices is 2.
The proof is just to
show you how to color it.
You clearly can't
get by with one color
if you've got any two
adjacent vertices.
The 2-colorable way is that you
just choose an arbitrary vertex
and-- call it the root-- but
you make the arbitrary choice
on what the root is.
And there's a unique path
from the root to every vertex,
using this unique
path characterization.
And so we're just
going to color vertices
by whether the path from the
root is of odd or even length.
If it's of even
length, color it red.
And if it's odd
length, color it green.
And so we wind up
alternating red and green.
And the fact is
that adjacent nodes
are going to be at a distance
where one is an odd distance
and one is an even
distance, which
is why this method of
coloring is going to work.
A general property
of 2-coloring is
that to figure out whether
or not a graph is 2-colorable
and how to do it,
is you just start.
Pick an arbitrary
vertex, color it red.
And then color all the
vertices adjacent to it green.
And keep going in that
way, coloring a vertex
with a color different from an
adjacent vertex that's colored,
until you get stuck.
If you don't get stuck
it's 2-colorable.
And if it's not 2-colorable,
you're guaranteed to get stuck.
So it's a very easy
way to figure out
if a graph is 2-colorable.
Another characterization of
2-colorability in general,
is that a graph is
2-colorable providing
that all the cycles that it has,
if any, are of even lengths.
Of course, a tree has
no cycles, so that
makes it 2-colorable for sure.